ihr habt ja vielleicht mitbekommen
deutschlands berühmteste youtube eltern
nämlich bibel julian haben vor kurzem in
das sie ihr kind ab jetzt nicht mehr vor
der öffentlichkeit verstecken wollen
sondern zeigen möchten jetzt haben ja
nicht alle eltern millionen abonnenten
aber wir nutzen alle social media und
wahrscheinlich fragen sich viele eltern
wie sie am besten mit sharon ting
umgehen sollen eine wortkombination und
parenting die sogar einzug in die
medienforschung genommen hat persönliche
meinungen gibt es ja viele zu diesem
thema aber ich hab mich gefragt gibt es
denn so was wie expertenmeinungen oder
sogar forschung und ich habe tatsächlich
ein paar ganz interessante dinge
gefunden die ich jetzt mit euch teilen
möchte und die vielleicht dabei helfen
die debatte ja ein bisschen sachlicher
und konstruktiver zu führen es gibt ja
auf jeden fall vorteile von social media
für eltern also abgesehen davon dass man
schöne momente mit anderen menschen
teilen kann und das eigene kind ist
natürlich für viele eltern das schönste
im leben nutzen viele eltern social
media auch um support und tipps zu
bekommen
laut einer amerikanischen umfrage des
pew research center sagten dass 2015
bereits 75 bis 80 prozent der befragten
eltern und von unserer web grafikerin
melanie weiß ich zum beispiel auch dass
gerade der anfang des elterndasein es
viele unsicherheiten und ängste mit sich
bringt wird man einfach nur froh ist zu
sehen dass es anderen auch so geht und
dass man die möglichkeit hat sich
auszutauschen
doch die nachteile liegen auch auf der
hand also einmal eingriff in die
privatsphäre der kinder ohne deren
zustimmung und eine internet alles was
irgendwann gepostet wird kann ich auch
bis ins erwachsenenalter noch verfolgen
und dann fragt man sich auch hat das
denn irgendwelche psychologischen
auswirkungen auf kinder gerade wenn man
jetzt als kind von youtube an aufwächst
die millionen abonnenten haben oder als
kind von reality stars wie den
kardashians ich finde es nicht so
sinnvoll jetzt zu fragen soll ich oder
soll ich nicht denn dafür ist das
internet und social media ein so großer
teil unseres lebens ich finde die viel
konstruktivere frage ist wie kann ich
mit den daten und informationen meiner
kinder im netz verantwortungsvoll
umgehen genau das haben sich auch diese
kinderärzte gefragt und folgende im
gelungen abgegeben erstens achtet auf
die privatsphäre und datenschutz
einstellungen der apps und plattform die
ihr benutzt und zwar nicht nur darauf
achten ob jetzt ein post öffentlich
privat oder nur für freunde ist sondern
kostenlose apps und plattformen
finanzieren sich ja über werbeeinnahmen
und das bedeutet dass persönliche
informationen an werbetreibende
weitergegeben werden so klickt man dann
eben als weiblicher nutzer werbung für
leben stift angezeigt und als männlicher
nutzer für holzfäller zubehör
außerdem sind social media plattformen
oft leicht hektar
man findet immer wieder wege private
posts von plattformen wie instagram oder
facebook als fremder doch einzusehen und
runter zu laden und selbst
augenscheinlich unschuldige kinder in
jugendfotos also die kinder müssen noch
nicht mal halb nackt sein können
missbraucht und etwa in datenbanken
pädophiler kreise gelangen social media
plattformen sind für solche fotos und
videos natürlich die nummer eins quelle
zweitens post über das kind durch lloyds
verfolgen wenn ihr euch ein google earth
oder ähnliches eine richtet bekommt die
ihm eine benachrichtigung wenn zum
beispiel jemand online den namen ihres
kindes erwähnt und so habt ihr ein auge
drauf wenn sich vielleicht informationen
weiter verbreiten also dass ein ich
möchte
drittens zeit vorsichtig wenn ihr
probleme oder structures eure kinder
teilt macht es wenn dann der klassiker
sind gesundheitliche probleme also
irgendetwas ist seltsam aber macht sich
sorgen man kriegt nicht sofort ein
arzttermin und dann erkundigt man sich
erst mal online ich kann natürlich nur
generell davon abraten sich online
medizinisch beraten zu lassen ist im
netz steht halt so viel quatscht also
lasst euch bitte professionell beraten
aber vor allem sind gesundheitliche
infos hochsensibel und nicht für die
öffentlichkeit gedacht also nicht
umsonst unterliegen erst seiner
schweigepflicht und das gilt nicht nur
für körperliche beschwerden sondern auch
für psychische zum beispiel so was wie
verhaltensauffälligkeiten wie hätten
seid vorsichtig mit dem namen eures
kindes und wo sich gerade aufhält
erklärt der name ist ein wichtiger
schlüssel um informationen über einen
menschen zu bekommen aber vor allem die
sache mit dem aufenthaltsort ist etwas
das wir alle auf dem schirm haben
sollten ob eltern oder nicht damit
stories die natürlich viel
eine mehr oder weniger live posten und
mit verlinkt im ort denkt immer drüber
nach ob das vielleicht ein
sicherheitsrisiko sein könnte oder ob
die story nicht doch lieber erstmal
speichert und dann postet wenn ihr von
dem ort schon weg seid und selbst wenn
ihr es nicht aktiv verlinkt immer auf
dem schirm haben dass fotos und videos
auch metadaten enthalten die dann zum
beispiel den ort preisgeben könnten
zumindest als foto gemacht wurde
punkt 5 ist klar würde ich sagen bezieht
ältere kinder mit 1 gibt ihnen die
möglichkeit veto einzulegen
ja ich denke die aktuelle debatte dreht
sich in erster linie um babys und kinder
die so jung sind dass sie eben noch
nicht mitreden können und da sind die
nächsten zwei punkte wichtig sechstens
kinder oder babyfotos immer nur komplett
bekleidet zeigen wie vorhin schon gesagt
also auch unschuldige fotos werden ja
schon missbraucht aber natürlich wenn
das kind dann auf der toilette ist im
bad am strand wie auch immer dann ist
das risiko für einen missbrauch
natürlich deutlich höher denkbaren post
heute immer daran wie sich eure kinder
in zukunft damit fühlen werden die
kampagne dein kind auch nicht weist
darauf hin dass man nichts von seinem
kind posten sollte was man eben auch
nicht so von sich selbst posten würde
egal wie süß oder lustig man das jetzt
gerade in diesem moment findet das geht
natürlich auch für die eltern die das
gesicht ihrer kinder unkenntlich machen
also die zwei sachen posten aber dann
blühen oder mocky draufpacken kann man
natürlich gerne machen wenn man das
möchte aber trotz allem ist es damit
nicht getan also es gibt viele
verschiedene dinge die man denken muss
passen dazu diese aktuelle studie bei
der jugendliche zwischen 12 und 14
befragt wurden welches posting verhalten
sie gerne von ihren eltern gesehen die
befragten jugendlichen fanden sharing
prinzipiell in ordnung also allein die
tatsache dass sie damals nicht gefragt
wurden oder nicht mitreden konnten war
nicht das problem sondern erst wenn
bestimmte grenzen überschritten worden
also wenn bilder oder peinlich
unangenehm waren oder negative
kommentare mit sich zogen die man
natürlich dann auch irgendwann zu lesen
bekommt auch over sharon ting war ihnen
unangenehm das heißt wenn man einfach zu
viel information preisgeld wenn der
ganze alltag nach außen getragen wird
also man man könnte sagen die dosis
macht das gift und das ist dann sogar
noch eltern gibt die ihre kinder zur
influenza machen also mit ihren kindern
ganze youtube kanäle oder insta profile
betreiben
mit kindern die so jung sind die das gar
nicht umfassend begreifen können also
dass das höchst problematisch ist ich
glaube darüber müssen wir gar nicht
reden ich würde noch zwei punkte
hinzufügen
es war 8 auch wie wir uns im netz
verhalten hat einfluss auf das leben
unserer kinder wenn ich mich jetzt hier
auf meinem youtube-kanal wie der letzte
depp verhalte dann kann das natürlich
negative auswirkungen haben auf alle
menschen die mit mir privat verbandelt
sind
dazu zählen natürlich auch meine kinder
wobei depp natürlich im auge des
betrachters steht die schwester von
kreta thunberg zum beispiel die selbst
nicht in der öffentlichkeit ist wird
gemobbt von leuten die kretas aktivismus
kacke finden gerade im doping hat er
jetzt durch das internet noch einmal
ganz andere dimensionen angenommen die
also ist noch mal ein ganz
grundsätzliches anderes problem das man
natürlich auch noch mal unabhängig davon
angehen müssten social interaction
overkill der nicht dass jetzt mal den
menschen sind ja soziale wesen und
unsere sozialen interaktionen werden
jetzt erweitert um soziale interaktionen
im netz und die können echt viel sein
ich persönlich bin zum beispiel echt
froh dass ich einfach schon 28 war als
ich mit youtube angefangen habe also als
erwachsene frau kann ich mit der flut an
kommentaren und der vielen
aufmerksamkeit und der gefahr dass man
seinen selbstwert an sowas wie likes
oder views knüpfen könnte kann ich ganz
entspannt umgehen weniger social media
folgt kann ich jetzt mal kurz placken
aber dann wisst ihr leider auch dass ich
phasen habe wo ich wochen oder
monatelang nichts pause einfach weil ich
ja gar nicht so viel bock hat und mir da
auch kein druck mache oder so aber ich
glaube mit 18
wäre ich mit dem ganzen trubel noch
nicht so gut klar gekommen also ich
finde das nicht nur ein negative
aufmerksamkeit belastet also
beleidigungen oder irgendwelche
sonstigen negativen kommentare sondern
dass zu viel aufmerksamkeit an sich
nicht ohne ist man kann ja einfach auch
darüber mal nachdenken bevor man jetzt
weiß nicht zu viel von seinen kindern
kostet selbst wenn sie es später nicht
peinlich finden sollten
setzt man sie ja trotzdem dieser
öffentlichen beurteilung und
aufmerksamkeit aus die social media nun
einmal mit sich bringt man halt auch
immer wieder dass social media durch den
ständigen vergleich und diese ganze
oberflächlichkeit unglücklichen ich
finde diese langzeitstudie ganz
interessant die
in england begleitet von 13 bis 16
die ergebnisse zeigen zunächst dass ein
häufiger gebrauch von social media für
mädchen aber nicht für jungs einhergeht
mit einer verminderung des wohlbefindens
und der lebenszufriedenheit aber hier
muss man ganz genau hinschauen die
probleme hin ganz spezifisch zusammen
mit mobbing also cybermobbing und mit
positiven dingen die wegen social video
auf der strecke bleiben wie zum beispiel
schlaf oder sport und wenn man den
einfluss dieser dinge statistisch
ausrechnet dann sieht man sowohl für die
jungs als auch wird die mädchen keinen
zusammenhang zwischen social media- und
eine verminderung der zufriedenheit es
kommt in dieser studie also weniger
darauf an ob man soziale medien an sich
ausgesetzt ist sondern ob man dort eben
mobbing erfährt oder ob das oft kosten
von schlaf- oder sport geht die
möglichkeiten im netz und unser medien
konsum das alles ändert sich so schnell
der zeit dass forschung und wissenschaft
kaum hinterherkommen also was wie
langzeitstudien sind total schwierig und
es gibt deswegen auch tatsächlich wenige
handfeste daten trotzdem denke ich dass
man die ergebnisse dieser studie auch
viele andere bereiche übertragen kann
nämlich es geht nicht in erster linie
darum ob wir social media nutzen oder
wie viel sondern es ist viel wichtiger
wie wir es nutzen und dass wir genau wie
im analogen leben verantwortungsvoll
handeln ich finde jedenfalls nicht
sinnvoll zu sagen das man pauschal
kinder nicht im internet zeigen sollte
einfach nur weil sie nicht mitreden
können denn ich werde jetzt bald mutter
ich werde bald viele entscheidungen für
mein kind treffen müssen es nicht
mitreden kann das fängt damit an welche
klamotten anziehen und geht bis hin zu
wichtigen medizinischen entscheidungen
die ich treffen werde und welche fotos
ich wie und mit wem teilt das ist
einfach noch eine weitere entscheidung
die alle eltern für sich und ihre kinder
einfach verantwortungsvoll treffen
müssen wie es bei euch haben eure eltern
auch schon mal peinliche kinderfotos von
euch eingescannt und dann im netz
hochgeladen und ihr fand es nicht so
cool oder wer von euch hat einen schon
kinder und wie geht ihr damit um habt
euch darüber schon gedanken gemacht ich
freue mich total darauf diese
eure kommentare zu lesen also ich freue
mich immer darauf eure kommentare zu
lesen aber dieses mal besonders wir
sehen uns nächste woche und bis dahin
bleibt sicher